I don't think there was any hatchet well
that's that's that's we're in a
political arena let me just say this
because I have some level of confidence
and actually joy and seeing diversity in
our caucus we are the Democratic Party
ever since I came here we have been
engaged in differences in a pent of
opinion in our caucus and that is a good
thing we are not a lockstep rubber-stamp
representation of anything except
representatives of our district and what
that means
so in our caucus we have our differences
respect that instead of making a big
issue of it respect that those are our
differences and how we express ourselves
as representatives of our districts is
our responsibility I've never seen
actually like yesterday we had 219 votes
for the bill if anybody asked any
questions about that
219 a very unified very unified caucus
in doing what we needed to do for the
American people even though it was a
compromise even though it was a
compromise I certainly wanted more but
it was a compromise when we win the
white house and we win the United States
Senate and we continue to win the House
of Representatives and we'll have more
leverage in that conversation but I
don't think they're ever I would never
even say that it was a hatchet but I do
think that we we sat down today we had a
good meeting and the congresswoman is a
very gracious member of Congress so
we've had a very positive conversation
about our districts and how we represent
them our country and how we need to meet
the needs the diversity of America and
the challenges we face in terms of
issues and how immigration and people
are respected I again referenced Ronald
Reagan
as opposed to the current occupant of
the White House so I feel I've always
felt I again it's like your and a family
and a family you have your differences
but you're still family is that having
your family your family always agree on
everything you do have meetings in your
family oh my god
oh my goodness well you may be a model
for us and we just had a meeting to
clear the air that's it
well I'm not going into that I just said
what I'm gonna say on that subject
anything else yes yeah we have a diverse
cause and let me see when I came to
Congress the fight was on how we deal
with what was happening at Central
America are then who would become
Speaker eventually Jim right but no no
he was Speaker when I got here but he
would then be the leader in the fight to
stop the aid to the Contras Republicans
went after him is rebut our caucus was
divided on the subject then as certainly
thereafter it was NAFTA very big
division in the caucus on NASA before
your time very big division on NAFTA and
then the war in Iraq differences of
opinion as you know I was ranked we may
not know a ranking member I was Adam
Schiff at the time but he's chairman I
was on the top Democrat we didn't have
the majority and I said that the
intelligence did not support the threat
they said you're you're calling the
president a liar send Michael I'm a liar
I'm stating a fact the intelligence does
not support the threat that this
administration is using as a
justification but what people said to me
then and I had been in Congress over ten
years by then you're never going
anyplace in this party unless you vote
for this war well I didn't vote for it
and a majority of our Democrats didn't
vote for it and senator senator Graham
didn't vote for who was Democrat in the
Senate a leader on the Intelligence
Committee in the house our members by
and large voted against the war in the
Senate they voted for so is a big
division among Democrats on that
Saturday that list goes on on these some
personality
issues in the rest they're minor we have
a big schism in our country between what
is happening could happen in this
Congress and what is happening in the
White House everybody knows we have to
keep our eye on the ball